we have the latest inflation numbers
these numbers have been much anticipated
there were
rumors flying around that year-over-year
inflation once march 2022 numbers were
added in would get into the double
digits over 10
and that didn't happen and we're going
to talk about expectations we're also
going to talk about what the number
means but first
we all know if we participate in the
american economy meaning if you buy
groceries
go out to eat
own a vehicle a gas vehicle pay
utilities i mean everything is more
expensive my electrical bill is up my
grocery bill is up people who have gas
vehicles see that gas is more expensive
we know intuitively because of our
experience in the economy that prices
are up and the question is how much and
in what sectors
and
we now have
that information and inflation has
indeed increased by the most
since 1981
and the consumer price index is up 8.5
percent now there are people confused
about what this means but the reporting
is also confusing when we talk about an
eight point five percent price increase
we don't mean
that in march prices went up eight four
eight point five percent however a lot
of the reporting makes it seem that way
i mean look at this yahoo finance
headline which says inflation rises by
the most since 1981 as the consumer
price index jumps 8.5 percent in march
i understand why some people are
confused but so that you know
this number means that in the year
ending march 2022
the consumer price index is up 8.5
the previous number was february to
february the new number eight point five
percent is march to march prices didn't
go up eight point five percent in march
they went up eight point five percent in
the year ending march now it's on on the
one hand why am i talking about this so
much on the other hand if you don't
understand that you don't have any idea
what's going on and there's people all
over twitter and all over my feed saying
can can you believe it
prices are up almost 10 percent in one
month no no they're not these are high
numbers these are the highest inflation
numbers since 1981 for a one year period
but unless we all are on the same page
about what this means
we're really not going to get anywhere
and the reporting doesn't doesn't make
it particularly more clear now you look
in more detail
um at the numbers and you see that there
are um a number of different areas that
that are sort of leading this some of
the biggest contributors to the increase
were food we know that we know groceries
are are up we joke a lot about mango
prices but but grocery prices are up
shelter
uh
rents and and home property uh
properties uh real estate and gasoline
and the index tracking gas prices surged
up uh 18.3
month on month in march
comprising more than half of the total
monthly increase so
half of the increase in prices in march
was gasoline alone
and um in february gasoline had a 6.6
monthly increase
so
this
this is if you want to have a real
conversation about this you kind of have
to get away from the politics because
there's a lot of this is just joe
biden's fault and of course there's
global inflation gas prices are up
everywhere
the most important aspects of this to me
are are kind of twofold one is the
reaction
why is the stock market up today if
these numbers are so terrible and as of
right now as we're filming the stock
market is up significantly today the
answer that we are taught and we can all
judge whether it makes sense or not
um
is that the market had already priced in
that the numbers could be even worse
there were rumors inflation could be
above ten percent now the actual
economic forecasts were exactly this
they were eight point four percent we
got eight point five percent year over
year but because the market now has the
certainty that it's not going to be
worse than expected the market is doing
well
some people just don't care okay but if
we want to analyze that that would be
one thing to think about
the other aspect of this is there are
lots of people pushing hot takes on
social media that this isn't the real
number that the real number is above 10
and that the metric of the consumer
price index doesn't accurately take that
into account well that's an argument
that you can have at any time
very often when unemployment numbers
come out you will see people come out of
the woodwork and they'll say you know
when in the unemployment system you stop
looking for work you're no longer
considered unemployed so the number is
not accurate
that's true but that's been a reality in
the unemployment system for 40 years
going all the way back to reagan is that
closer to 50 years now
the point is
you can't
cherry pick when you point out the
limitations of a metric to try to make a
point about only the latest numbers
that's dishonest this is the way that
we've measured these things for a long
time uh my prediction and my prediction
is worth as little as everybody else's i
mean i i'm the first to tell you humans
are terrible at making economic
predictions my prediction and this is
just an opinion
is that we're basically at the peak here
of inflation
and that we're going to start seeing a
slow decline in year-over-year inflation
maybe starting next month with this
month's numbers but more likely in the
next two to three months that that's my
prediction what might delay it a little
bit would be gas prices in general tend
to go up over the summer uh more people
driving taking road trips etc and if
that's the case it may push it off even
a little more but my sense is
within the next four months
we are going to start to see a decline
that that unless something dramatic
changes should continue let's talk a
little bit about the coveted pandemic we
may be approaching what what might be
the first so what wave and i'm not the
person who came up with that there's a
good atlantic article that uses that
term we had the original wave
we had delta
we had
omicron and we may be getting to the
first so what wave where
most people may just not do anything
differently we just don't know
but
pandemic fatigue aside
it's starting to look like something may
be happening so a few headlines
philadelphia is restoring indoor mask
mandates as cases rise we've gotten away
from almost any mask mandates yes
transportation federally although that
may go away april 18th although it may
not now that the numbers are starting to
rise in some places again
um
medical facilities in i think most
states all i don't i don't even remember
if that's federal in most places you go
to the doctor you're still supposed to
wear a mask at least in the northeast
um but we are starting to see some
things happen again philadelphia will
restore its indoor mask mandate the
associated press reporting confirmed
covet cases up more than 50 in 10 days
that's a predetermined threshold where
the city says masks go back on indoors
this is being driven by the ba2
sub-variant of omicron
the original omicron was ba1
ba2 is this sub-variant of omicron u.s
state department orders all
non-emergency government staff in
shanghai china to leave as covid surges
[Music]
however the chinese foreign ministry is
not pleased with this on saturday
chinese foreign ministry spokesperson
xiao li jian
said the u.s characterization of china's
coveted policy was a groundless
accusation and that the chinese side has
assisted foreign diplomats and consular
staff on covid related
issues
this is in response to the u.s state
department warning about the arbitrary
enforcement of local laws
universities reinstating mask mandates
amid covet surge
uh the american university announced
monday it's putting a mask mandate back
on in dc colombia georgetown johns
hopkins rice universities are also doing
this the reason the highly transmissible
ba2 sub variant
an average of more than 31 000 new covet
cases across the country
covet could be surging in the u.s and we
might not even know about it this is
also an important issue and i know a lot
of people are sick of hearing about this
we know
that there is less testing going on
we also know that a lot of the home
testing is not being reported to
authorities so a lot of people this
started to be an issue during the the
first omicron wave in december
it's an even bigger issue now where
increasingly a lot of people are testing
at home
testing positive
and then they throw the test out and
they go i'm positive and that's it that
doesn't show up in the numbers anywhere
uh not not to you know i'm not i've no
reason to think sam cedar is doing this
but we sadly learned yesterday that our
friend sam cedar from the majority
report has tested positive he's had a
bunch of different negative tests didn't
feel well now he's positive
i don't know what type of a test that
was but the point i'm making is without
accusing sam of anything if sam's
eventual positive test was a home test
that's not automatically counted
anywhere unless sam reports it and
because of the decrease decreased not
only in people seeking tests but also
the decrease in some of these municipal
and federal testing sites
we we just know
we're almost certainly not capturing all
of the cases that are going on so what's
going to happen i don't know
i am
convinced that the threshold for people
going back into a cautious state is much
higher much much higher than it was
before
and what i mean by that is a slight
increase in cases and deaths at this
point for social reasons
is not going to kind of drive us back
in terms of our uh precautions i think
people are much more comfortable
accepting a certain level of risk i'm
not immune to that i went to las vegas
last week
i i there were there was not a mask in
sight i was around thousands of people
and um
thankfully i didn't i didn't get sick
and uh you know when i got back i i
didn't see people for four days until i
really knew i was in the clear but would
i have done that at a previous time you
know probably not at the same time the
numbers look a lot better so we're going
to have to see what happens i think you
will absolutely see
a much more stark difference between
states
as in all likelihood cases continue to
rise and eventually hospitalizations do
as well
let me know your perspective on this let
me know what you're doing let me know
what you're seeing in your state you can
find me on twitter at deepakman and one
week from today at 6 pm eastern we'll
have the next david pakman show town
hall i hope you'll join everybody gets
to ask questions and it will be
streaming live on the pacman live
youtube channel
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
remember that we are a viewer and
listener supported program i would love
it if you signed up at joinpackman.com
we do an extra show every single day for
our members you can also gift
memberships we have nearly 700 people
who have asked for a membership they
can't afford one they're on a list
and you can donate memberships to these
people just sign up at joinpakman.com
and check the box this is a gift when
you go through the process we will in
order of request
um giveaway memberships as they come in
you can request a free membership at
davidpakman.com
free membership
okay this i almost missed this because i
was traveling over the weekend but my
colleague john told me that there was
another one of these defeat the mandates
rallies in los angeles over the weekend
this is one of the most dangerous
dystopian events that i've ever seen
it's also hilarious in that they bring
in speakers that are like the most
boring speakers in the world completely
uninspiring in any way
um and every every detail about this
event is absolutely horrifying uh we're
going to look at some of these clips
lara logan spoke she's the now fox host
who has gone completely off the rails
jimmy dore spoke he's a
i can't even really call him a leftist
he's sort of like a
he's kind of like a neo-contrarian i
guess is what i would say
um
he spoke robert malone spoke who's this
doctor who's made a lot of headlines by
being
skeptical of vaccines and pushing
unproven treatments and this type of
thing and this is scary in every sense
so let's just look at a few of these
clips first and foremost they brought up
a kid to speak a 14 year old kid whose
mannerisms and delivery are very
trumpian they brought him up this might
be the most disturbing moment when they
bring up this kid to speak against
vaccines take a look at this
we are here in grand park los angeles
gathered do you want to know why we're
gathered here
because it's time to take back our
country
from who there's like no mandates left
what are you talking about
this is a freedom activist lucky basery
[Applause]
stand and fight
we cannot let the weaklings take us down
the brainwash will not defeat us america
will be shrunk again and california will
be liberated people
it's got a kind of mix of the political
ignorance and scientific ignorance we've
come to expect from
the anti-vaccine movement
combined with a kind of
tent church revival vibe
our country
is in peril deep peril
that's true
but it's in peril because
people are willing to go more people are
willing to go to a rally like this
rather than to a rally to actually solve
real problems that we have we are it is
in peril but it's it's because of these
people constitution is being disregarded
as nothing more than a piece of paper
and i will not let it stand
[Applause]
this is not a democratic issue this is
not a republican issue it is an american
issue
freedom
all americans deserve to be free our
founding fathers founded this country
all right so i i i am getting a little
bit nauseous i don't know how much more
of that we can do so that's
extraordinarily disturbing but then the
entire event was was just filled with
some of the most ignorant people that
don't know anything and it's the the
blind leading the blind we'll look at a
couple examples here's one guy who makes
some really strange claims about
everything including sweden
they're gonna talk later they're coming
at around three o'clock but let me end
let me end by the critical issue here
this is about the coming for your
children
there is no science there's no data
we've looked at the science we looked at
the science in sweden zero debts
zero we looked at the science in germany
we looked at the dali settle study that
was published that showed in the french
alps
one infected child which exposed 109
contacts they followed them
not one instance of secondary
transmission okay so i don't know what
he means by no one died in sweden like i
i genuinely don't know what he means
if he means no one died of covet in
sweden obviously that's not true
uh we're putting deaths by age up on the
screen
if he means no children died of covet in
sweden i mean that's also not true
sweden is has a much smaller sweden's
like a u.s state right i mean it is a
relatively small population
15 kids nine and younger died of covet
in sweden eight kids 10 to 19. i mean i
don't know what he means
but obviously people died in sweden so
that was weird then this was interesting
um jimmy dore spoke
and he's reading off of a piece of paper
everybody including jimmy he doesn't
even seem to know what he's reading
and
it it's just all so weird dates and
passports are the major issue of the day
with millions of people protesting
against them worldwide in fact what has
become known as the medical freedom
movement is arguably the biggest and
most diverse international movement in
world history
really an inspiring speaker huh
and you're part of it yeah
vaccine mandates vaccine passports are
among the most vile unconstitutional
immoral unscientific discriminatory and
outright criminal policies ever enforced
upon this population
that's the black caucus or the great
party white supremacists
don't turn on each other i have more in
common with every person here than i do
with bill gates
yeah and i guess what he means is like
even though he's ostensibly on the left
and this is like a mostly right-wing
nuttery rally
he has more in common with them i mean
like yeah we know that that that seems
pretty clear another great inspirational
speaker it's hard not to hear dr robert
malone speak and just feel energy
coursing through you
dignity
and community
integrity is a commitment to truth in
what you say how you live and how you
treat others
dignity flows from respect for ourselves
for each other and for the world we live
in
community is what binds us together it's
what's gone wrong
is what binds us together to each other
and gives our lives purpose and meaning
an absolutely electric dr robert malone
reading off of a laptop
these are the three things we must
recover if we will heal the problem is
not the virus
the problem is the damage that has been
done to us as human beings and as a
community
[Applause]
on the other day
the doctor of the roman catholic church
who famously said the truth is like a
lion
you don't have to defend it
let it loose it will defend itself
[Applause]
um naomi wolfe was there she's also sort
of like someone formerly i guess
associated with the left who's gone
completely out of her mind
she appears to have almost like a
psychotic event
or some kind of mania check this out
there are a lot of moms out here in dads
but i want to speak as a mom and as a
stepmom
you hurt our kids
and
watch out
because
you have never faced the rage of
thousands of furious mothers and
stepmothers
and it's like what are you guys
protesting against again i don't even
really understand what what why the
event is happening they then interviewed
a doctor michael huang
who
claims he's treated three thousand
coveted patients and he uses this
bizarre phrase where he says he has
helped a thousand kids come off of masks
almost like some kind of drug treatment
program
it's a bizarre 60 seconds of video there
are some cities that are still holding
on to mass mandates even for toddlers
what would you say to parents that are
wanting to believe maybe your message um
what would you say the physician's
view is of children wearing masks
we have helped over a thousand kids come
off mask i have treated
what does that mean we've this they
brought them in
and we detoxed them and it was tough
we gave them the uh we we gave
and we got them off of the masks it was
tough they were sweating they had the
cold sweats but we got them off the
masks few children died with covet
never had to actively prescribe any
medication there's a tremendous
stratification
between the young and the old
young people basically
very very mild disease so no fear i need
to let the parents know do not be afraid
yeah i mean look you know it's again
most people recover and most people
recover without taking anything no they
they cite that like that should really
change our perspective most people don't
die of covid
most people don't die of cove most
people don't need any medication to
recover
but that doesn't make a plan for dealing
with a pandemic is it not not surprising
and then lastly
there was anti-trans stuff at the defeat
the mandates rally as well
you tell me what the connection is
between anti-trans and anti-mass
anti-mass and anti-vaccine in the dark
you eat when you're hungry and wait
i've got one for you i don't know if
you're ready for this right
men are not women
wait a minute wait a minute what a
powerful message
for medical freedom there huh so an
extraordinarily dangerous event and
again the really the really scary and
horrible thing is
that people go to this stuff
these things these movements have
followers in the united states
and um it is really scary because we we
all want to solve real problems
and when you've got a not insignificant
portion of the population buying into
this stuff what what a tr really a
tragic event everyone who is there
should be absolutely humiliated i want
to do a short update on a story we did
yesterday yesterday i told you
that lizelle herrera has been charged
with murder
for a quote self-induced abortion
those charges have now been dropped and
the entire story is getting even more
more strange so newsweek reporting
abortion murder charge against texas
woman spurs calls for a hipaa lawsuit an
actual hippa lawsuit not like someone
asks marjorie taylor green are you
vaccinated and she goes that's my hipaa
no marjorie it's not um
the article says
officers arrested the 26 year old on
charges of intentionally and knowingly
causing the abortion sparking
international backlash against texas
abortion restrictions
she miscarried at a hospital and
allegedly confided to hospital staff
that she attempted to induce her own
abortion and she was reported to the
authorities by hospital staff
star county district attorney said
sunday he would drop charges against
herrera but the incident led some
critics of texas abortion policy to
argue the arrest stemmed from a hipaa
violation meaning that medical
professionals disclosed patient
information and they are suggesting that
she sue so there's two different things
here first of all
the she was she was charged and we said
what the hell are they thinking and then
as soon as it became national news they
say there was no criminal act we're
dropping the charges this is the office
that indicted her in the first place so
what were they doing were they testing
the waters to see what they could get
away with will they do it next time and
maybe there won't be a public outcry and
then you actually go through with the
prosecution of a woman for abortion
what is it that they're trying to do are
they trying to instill a sort of
chilling effect on women in texas uh
about listen you you can get arrested if
you get an abortion we don't know okay
that's one side of it and then the other
side of it is was it a hipaa violation
for the hospital to call the police
there is a hippa exception
for if you suspect someone committed a
crime in good faith and how do you how
do you know if it's in good faith if you
as a medical provider suspect someone
committed a crime there are exceptions
to hipaa they are very narrow
and you have to if i understand
correctly believe the crime was
committed on the premises meaning the
hospital or wherever
there's no indication
that the attempt at a self-induced
abortion
took place at the hospital and thus as i
understand it this would not qualify for
that hipaa exemption
it has to be investigated but also
remember that abortion is not a crime
um so the entire thing is a mess
it should be looked into whether there
was a hipaa violation but the good news
is at least in this case charges were
dropped although we can speculate about
what the broader goal was of bringing
charges in the first place we'll have
more on this on our instagram at david
pakman show and i hope to hear from you
what do you think the goal was here
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show today we're going to be speaking
with dr steven novella who is a
neurologist host and producer of the
award-winning podcast the skeptic's
guide to the universe and also lead
author of the best-selling book by the
same name i really appreciate your time
it's great having you on today
oh thanks for having me on it's great to
be here you've uh the book and the
podcast really the these are
excellent sources for thinking about uh
how to evaluate why we believe the
things we believe why others believe the
things they they believe how to engage
with epistemology and critical thinking
which is is so important right now
we could start this conversation any of
a number of different ways can you talk
a little bit first generally about the
approach you find most useful when
engaging with people with different
views to kind of create a baseline from
which we can have conversations about do
we believe things that are that are
actually true what's the the general
approach that you propose
yeah well i think you know saying that
we need a baseline is a good approach
the first step is always to establish
some common ground
because if you don't have common ground
pretty much you're just fighting right
you're not talking you're not engaging
you're not
going to make any progress and you might
have to back up quite a ways to find out
where that common ground is people make
a lot of assumptions they don't even
realize how many different things go
into their world view and how many
assumptions are in there and that
somebody else might not share those same
assumptions so even things like how do
we know what's real
or what evidence is reliable evidence
etc you know once and once you establish
that common ground you might you might
actually also be surprised to find how
that you have a lot more common ground
than you may think that's all that's
another common experience and then you
can build slowly carefully from there
uh you know what are the goals what you
know what how are we going to figure out
you know how to how to proceed here uh
so that i think there's a general
picture if you just back up and find
common ground that's a good way to begin
there are
some pitfalls sometimes in a lot of
these conversations and i'm curious as
to your thoughts about how to navigate
them you know there's these concepts
that are often bandied about like
dunning-kruger the idea that someone
lacks
the
ability or knowledge to understand that
they are not necessarily fully equipped
to have a certain conversation which
which comes off as very uh insulting
sometimes to say to someone in whatever
words you want to use you know
dunning-kruger may be limiting your
ability to engage meaningfully in this
conversation
the reality is sometimes people are kind
of in over their heads so what what are
some more productive ways maybe to
establish that someone may just not have
all of the information to engage
yeah so you know i think the first
realization is that dunning-kruger
and
logical fallacies critical thinking
skills you know media literacy these
things don't apply to other people they
apply to you they apply to everyone so
if you're using you know these critical
thinking concepts as a weapon in order
to
you know essentially knock down or
attack somebody else you're doing it
wrong you know these mainly are
methods of policing your own thinking
and so like don and krueger it doesn't
mean some people are or they don't have
the information to evaluate
their ignorance it's everybody does just
to a different degree degree on
different topics but unless you are at
the cutting edge of world expertise in a
very you know narrow topic
it applies to you there you don't have
enough information to really
meaningfully engage in you know
how we know what we know about some
cutting edge tech especially technical
topic um and so the the other half of
that is what we call neuropsychological
humility right so that we all have to be
humble i'm not saying that like you're
dumb or you can't you know engage in
critical thinking or there are you're
cognitively biased it's we all are we
all need to confront the way our brains
work the way our logic tends to work and
you know again this gets back to the con
to the common ground things like we all
need to work together to identify the
limitations in our knowledge identify
maybe some of the biases that we're
working with and then again see if we
can build from there to to some kind of
common ground
one of the things that particularly
during the pandemic often comes up
and i get a lot of emails from people
about this as well is someone will say
yeah okay so the cdc and the who and my
local doctor they they say this
but did you see that like gary null for
example is a name that people often
email me about or they'll say or dr john
campbell on youtube said this about
ivermectin or whatever
and sometimes i have the instinct like
when callers say this stuff to talk a
little bit about credentials like to say
well you you know dr john campbell he
has a doctorate in teaching nursing he's
not a medical doctor but at the same
time i know that it's sort of an appeal
to authority but i
recognize it might be relevant for
someone to know whether we're talking to
a medical doctor or not like it seems
relevant but at the same time it's kind
of just like going right to credentials
what what makes sense when it comes to
something like that
this is perhaps the trickiest thing that
we engage with because it's basically
dueling experts right and you can find
an expert to say whatever you want to
support whatever position you you want
to have and you feel like i'm listening
to the experts i got these experts over
here and this phenomenon has been
weaponized it's not like it's just a
random thing there are people who are
trying to lead you down a path paved
with these you know cherry-picked
outlier expert opinions or pseudo expert
opinions or sometimes they're not
experts at all
and you know you have to be able to pick
your way through that but again if
you're not an expert
how do you do that again you're not in a
position to evaluate which experts are
legitimate so you need to have some
basic algorithms that you use some basic
things you know
red flags or processes that you go
through to have at least a reasonable
way of evaluating people who have more
expertise in an area than you do
so
i think they're probably the biggest
thing to do is to listen to a consensus
of many experts over an opinion of one
expert no one expert is definitive every
any one person can be wrong could be a
complete outlier but if you have
you know
uh organizations that have some
legitimacy like they're not an
ideological organization or like you
know um
exist for for the purpose of pushing an
agenda but they're like a university or
a professional organization etc and they
say yeah we put together a panel of
experts and they recommend this this is
how they like the american medical
association for example or you know any
other like medical professional
organization who said yeah we reviewed
the evidence and this this is the
standard of care that we think is the
case or
you know the intergovernmental you know
panel on climate change yeah we have 3
000 climate scientists got together and
they go yeah this is 95 likely what's
going on
you know you can't
put that up against one you know one
person
as an expert in isolation and say that
they're equivalent um so i think that's
if you just did that just sought out
you know what seemingly objective
um consensus opinion among the greatest
number of experts possible you're much
more likely to be correct than listening
to one guy on youtube no matter what his
credentials seem to be when it comes to
medications would it be rather than what
one person says or a a small study one
doctor did saying the standard is sort
of like the randomized controlled trial
and that that would be what we look to
yeah well that's certainly now you're
saying what what is the standard of
evidence within that field right so
certainly with with drugs and with a lot
of medical treatments the standard is
the randomized um trial
but it's more than that actually it's a
systematic review of multiple randomized
controlled trials gotcha one trial
doesn't really tell you anything because
any one trial could be a quirky result
it could be you know you don't know what
the pattern is statistically speaking
you can't make many firm conclusions
based on one study but once you see what
the pattern of evidence is among many
studies and that requires an expert
systematic review which is a great way
by the way to get a good quick idea of
what is the consensus of opinion about
this medical topic is look at some you
know high quality systematic reviews uh
you know then that tells you what's
likely to be the case because then
you're seeing a pattern of evidence not
just one piece of evidence
right now uh what set of false factually
false beliefs i'm not using the term
conspiracy theory because sometimes it's
not really a conspiracy theory it's just
people believe something that's not true
what what's the most concerning or
to you or that you believe is most
damaging to us
in society right now
well i mean certainly anti-vaccine
attitudes are incredibly harmful
especially in the middle of a pandemic i
mean it's definitely slowing down and
impairing our ability to tamp down
this pandemic
increasing the odds that new variants
are going to emerge and prolong you know
the pandemic so that's definitely you
know in the short term that's probably
the biggest thing long term i have to
say climate change you know we need to
be the conversation we need to be having
is how best to avoid the worst case
scenarios of climate change how how to
mitigate the the expensive you know and
very disruptive effects that are that
are already happening and are and we
know we're going to be getting worse
rather than the endless discussion of is
it happening or
you know trying to do whatever we can to
avoid
you know reducing fossil fuel company
profits which is i think what most of
the you know the pushback is really all
about
um we sort of get stuck
spinning our wheels and again that's
that's on purpose that's by design you
know
literally there are paid
pr experts who spread you know fear
uncertainty and doubt to delay things as
much as possible it's just so easy for
that to happen
because you know it's just easy to
generate the sort of false skepticism
this uh
you know what i call science denial uh
in order to prolong the discussion in
this preliminary phase of is it
happening is there anything we can do
about it and then of course to sort of
nitpick and shoot down any proposed
solutions rather than engage
meaningfully with
you know what is the best solutions you
know to to this problem what will
minimize any short-term negative
economic impact what's going to have the
greatest chance of succeeding long-term
etc and there's lots of great you know
proposals
on the table and it's happening it's
just we just need to accelerate it so
that we can
you know again avoid um risking some
tipping points or or the worst outcome
so
in the long run for humanity i think
that's the biggest you know issue that
we're facing there are people who
sometimes categorize false beliefs with
a very fine line between them the sort
of the ones that are materially damaging
like you point out
climate science denial preventing us
from actually putting in place you know
some real infrastructure here to deal
with this or anti-vaxx is
literally it prolonging a
pandemic and then they'll say okay and
then there's a fine line and on the
other side there's stuff that's
basically benign like flat earth for
example yeah i've spoken to
psychologists who specialize in um
paranoid and conspiracist beliefs and
and different people who say it's not
really that fine of a line because often
something seemingly benign like flat
earth belief
is associated with people with
anti-semitic conspiracy theories that
they believe or there's overlap with the
anti-vaxx movement or whatever can you
give us your sense of whether there
really are these two categories or
whether it's much more of a gray area oh
there's there aren't two categories it's
all just a continuum of one thing okay
there's there's certainly more or less
direct harm or demonstrable harm from
certain belief systems like if you
believe that modern medicine is a
conspiracy you know and and you should
treat all things with with uh
prayer or drinking your own urine or
whatever something bizarre like that
people actually believe by the way uh
then that yeah that's sort of you could
easily easily see how immediately
harmful that can be uh there's the other
beliefs are like flat earther for
example you may or belief in ghosts is
one we all who cares if people believe
in ghosts it's the the harm is not as
obvious but it's still there um you may
need to dig a little bit to see what the
tangible physical harm is but there's
also epistemological harm right when
people believe in magic when they are
don't understand the basics of how
science is working when they believe
it's all a conspiracy you are setting
them up for the harmful conspiracy to
come the more immediate obviously
harmful thing um so and sometimes it's
not that
long a trip there if you so if you
believe in magic you believe in you know
astrology or whatever
then you may are you're much more likely
to be
hoodwinked by let's say um
a psychic who you know we know there are
fraudulent psychics out there who steal
millions of dollars from people i mean
it's that's not harmless
so you know
the the harm may be a little bit more
secondary and harder to quantify
but it's it's there and when you do this
you know for a living for a long time
you see you see the harm it you know
even if it's a little bit downstream uh
there's tremendous harm from believing
in magic it makes you incredibly
vulnerable it is not isolated and so you
know we should not think of these things
as benign at all
do we all have some of these beliefs
like for example i think of myself as
you know someone who follows science and
i i ask myself why do i believe this or
that but just like to pick something
random
oftentimes when i'm traveling somewhere
new and eating some food i've not had
i'll mention i really hope this doesn't
make me sick and i think on some level i
think that by mentioning it
i'm kind of like putting it out and it's
like less likely that a weird new food
in some new country will i don't really
believe that i know that the thing i say
doesn't actually make a difference but
it's sort of like one of these it's a
false belief it doesn't really have an
impact on whether a food will make me
sick do we all have some of these things
do you think
oh sure so
no one is intellectually pristine right
so you know humans are predisposed to um
superstitious thinking like what you're
saying and sometimes you know we engage
in that for fun or for comfort uh or for
because of tradition or ritual when we
know intellectually like yes there's no
magic here this is not actually true i
cannot ward off food poisoning by saying
i hope this isn't poisonous but you
still do it that's i mean that's i think
is benign if you know intellectually
this is not true
and it's just part of just human
behavior
although you know some people like to
police that within themselves as well
just
you know because they think it could
help keep their keep their critical
thinking skills focused which is fine as
well
um but also in terms of what we actually
believe no one's you know belief system
is or what they hold to be true is
perfect either right it's just
impossible to get to that point where
yes i purged myself of all inaccurate
conclusions and false beliefs and i
everything i believe is 100 you know
accurate true and precise
that's that's an aspirational goal that
we will never get to the real difference
between people are those who engage in
metacognition and those who don't what's
metacognition it's basically thinking
about thinking it's turning a analytical
eye towards your own thinking processes
and trying to understand how you come to
conclusions how you come to believe
things examining improving tweaking that
process being open to changing your
beliefs based upon evidence and logic
etc
and those people who don't really
actively engage in metacognition they
sort of go with their psychological
process level they're just sort of
they're following the the current you
know the mental current to whatever
conclusion it brings them to
and not examining the process we're
going to pause our conversation there
with neurologist dr stephen novella the
skeptic's guide to the universe podcast
and book we will post our full extended
conversation on youtube at youtube.com
slash the david pakman show
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
okay so yesterday we did this fox news
has gone silent on ivermecton's story
and i explained to you that very early
on 300 plus mentions of ivermectin by
fox news host saying it's good and
people are uh being treated by it and
it's being covered up and all this
different stuff and then we got real
randomized controlled trials which as dr
stephen novella told us would sort of be
our gold standard for evidence on
medication and the randomized control
trials say ivermectin doesn't work for
covid and whoops zip their lips fox news
and everybody goes completely silent
like it never even happened
until
yesterday
this is the next level in gaslighting
fox news propagandist sean hannity
is now saying
i warned my audience about ivermectin
the studies don't say that it works
this is such a brazen rewrite attempt to
rewrite history he can't be allowed to
do it
it's classic revisionist history
uh and media matters put together this
great article hannity's new lies that he
warned his audience about ivermectin uh
we have a clip which they put together
you're going to hear hannity now just a
couple days ago say
i was telling people
there's i don't know about this
ivermectin thing and then you're going
to hear all the times he talked about
ivor mech dinner some of the times check
this out by the way that i had i've been
telling people i ever met and linda is
that not the one thing that i kept
saying there's not a single study that
that i've seen that shows that it works
one hundred percent
as well as other proactive treatments
and practices were already helping cover
19 patients all across the country now
when you say ivermectin is helping
covind patients you're saying it works
therapeutics hydroxychloroquine
ivermectin regeneron when you talk about
ivermectin and regeneron and incredible
therapeutics that are now being used to
treat not just breakthrough cases but
all cases that includes yes the model
colonial cocktail no by the way mono
colonial is just one of it's it's it's
one of my it's almost better than
trump's rum reservoir for
as regeneron the eli lilly version of
regeneron even yes hydroxychloroquine
ivormectin and listen this is my
business so i i'm constantly reading
they've never heard of regeneron or
ivermectin ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine that show that taken
early it can mitigate symptoms of
covalent 19. when you say ivermectin
mitigates the symptoms of covet 19
you are saying it works you're not
saying
in some limited place it seems like it
but be careful because it's not really a
trial
this is
classic revisionist history
they get not hannity but in total fox
gets more than 300 promotions of
ivermectin they say not only that it
works but that it's a conspiracy to
prevent it from being used i mean going
above and beyond what the evidence shows
and then hannity goes
i've been saying be careful about this
from the start i said it because we
don't know that it works this reminds me
of when trump
in 2018 it's a very dystopian line
said you can't even believe what you're
seeing but it's all working out and just
remember
what you're seeing and what you're
reading is
not
what's happening right even what you see
is not what's happening
how do you know what's happening well
trump tells you
but of course applied to fox news
they told you that ivermectin worked
they told you that they
didn't want you to know ivermectin
worked
they told you that the pharmaceutical
companies wanted you to get a vaccine
instead of
ivermectin or regeneron for financial
reasons even though regeneron's way more
profitable than vaccines on a per
regimen basis
and now they're telling you i warned you
all along if you had listened to me you
would have known there's no evidence
this is the suspension of disbelief that
is required
to buy into this cult
and they're willing to do it and they've
shown that they're willing to do it
the uh
the grift continues actually it's not
even really the griff it's more the is
it the cover-up
uh we now have
a new report
that the gift records
for donald trump and mike pence
they're just missing
we they're gone
the state department says
nbc news reporting the executive office
of the president
did not submit information about gifts
received by trump and his family from
foreign leaders in the year 2020
this is a
this is quite literally how you track
the emoluments adherence to the
emoluments clause of the constitution
you know when we talk about
people in office receiving gifts and
things of value from foreigners this was
an issue during the russia investigation
this is how we track it this is how we
hold them accountable for 2020 the
records are just missing the article
goes on to say
the state department says it is unable
to compile a complete and accurate
accounting of gifts presented to trump
and other officials during his last year
in office the data is missing from the
white house
in a report to be published in the
federal register next week
the department says the executive office
of the president
did not submit information about gifts
received by trump and his family from
foreign leaders in 2020.
wow it also says the general services
administration didn't submit information
about gifts given to mike pence and
staffers the state department said it
sought the missing information from
where from the national archives and
records administration and the gsa but
was told that quote potentially relevant
records are not available because of
access restrictions to retired records
wow
the report notes the lack of gift
information
could be related to internal oversights
as the protocol office neglected to
submit the request prior to bub
when the trump administration ended
however it also noted there has been a
quote this is like the understatement of
the century there's been a lack of
adequate record keeping pertaining to
diplomatic gifts
during trump's white house reign
i mean listen
maybe check mar-a-lago for those records
as well i don't know
um and now there are there there's the
reaction oh everybody does this this so
every administration does this actually
no
go back to the guardian report from 2018
we learned that the saudis gave barack
obama and his aides jewels
worth thousands of dollars according to
ex-advisor ben rhodes
they got quote suitcases full of jewels
on a 2009 trip and they were immediately
turned over to the state protocol office
no missing records no question marks we
know exactly what went on this is this
is a big difference here
between the two administrations and you
know it
it's one of these things where
individually well
the documents that trump ate he ate
because they thought they tasted like
doritos and so you don't have to worry
about that and the documents he flushed
thought they might have e coli on them
and trump wanted to get him out of there
and then the documents that he brought
to mar-a-lago
right i'm kidding around about the
explanations but that there's
individually you can say this was an
oversight and that was an accident and
then trump ripped him up because that's
what he's used to but we taped them back
together
but then you take the totality and you
you have to say this is a pattern and
one of the things that investigators
look at you know we talk about there are
crimes that are really difficult to
prove because they go to state of mind
i know this is like a broken record but
perjury
people lie in court all the time
and sometimes the lies are really hard
to prove like for example there's a
technique where you can go in when
you're supposed to give
testimony and your your
you testify in court and you're asked
about things and you don't want to lie
you don't want to give a false answer
so you say you don't recall now
sometimes saying you don't recall can
get you into trouble because good
lawyers that are prepared for false i
don't recalls have a line of questioning
and they have records and they can
actually show you did recall when
someone else asked you about it or
whatever so say lying about i don't
recall has its risks but sometimes for a
well-prepared witness
dishonest i don't recalls
can get you out of trouble and you are
lying you do recall and it's very hard
to prove and that's why you rarely see
perjury charges okay that's just one
example uh when it comes to
um
sedition for example sedition and maybe
i can even pull up
um
the definition conduct or speech meant
to incite people to rebel against an
authority okay you know john so with
sedition there's an aspect of saying
well it's not only what you said but it
was your intent in getting people to
rebel against the established order or
the government or what these things can
be can be difficult to prove but context
and a pattern
is something that can be used to try to
show
what was in the mindset of an individual
and when you see all the things trump
knew were wrong right he said hillary is
irresponsible with the
with with sensitive information and
private email and not keeping records so
he knew that these things were wrong to
do
and then trump rips up records eats
records flushes records steals records
spills secrets to a russian spy
recruiter in the oval office that we got
from our ally israel you see the pattern
of him doing things which we know he
knew they were wrong because he
criticized hillary for doing them
then it's hard to say that this isn't a
pattern and that this is deliberate
action right i mean it it just is what
it is will there be consequences
probably not
but i do have a voicemail that goes to
that let's go to that next we do have a
voicemail number it is available to you
24 hours a day the number is 219 to
david p
you can call anytime
some people leave 20 voicemails in a row
and typically when that happens they
just get deleted we don't have the
ability to field that much material but
here is someone who called in
who has a prediction
about merrick garland the midterms and
charges against donald trump take a
listen
this is jonathan in los angeles please i
believe merrick garland is going to wait
until after the midterms to a lump
to
indict trump and his cronies
to avoid any
appearance of being political
and when which case we're going to have
a
huge
huge
case of
special elections across the country
i i don't see that as likely and
there are some folks emailing me about
trump indictments where it's starting to
sound a little bit like this i don't
mean this to be insulting but it's sort
of like the trump people who were saying
okay before december 13th this thing's
going to be overturned well it's going
to be before january 6th
it'll be by the inauguration it'll be by
march april early summer late summer
halloween thanksgiving
and like it's just not gonna happen
um i don't think merrick garland is
waiting for the midterms to indict trump
and his cronies i i just don't i see no
evidence of that uh and
unless you know joe biden's not running
for reelection
either way
i think there's also a risk politically
to doing it after the midterms anyway
so i just don't see that as a likely
scenario but i would love to be wrong
and i'm willing to have my mind changed
by the facts changing on the ground we
have a tremendous bonus show for you
today we are going to talk about the
average workday work from home higher
than ever during the pandemic work day
length
longer than ever during the pandemic on
average people are working an extra full
hour a day
we'll talk about it
elon musk
has changed his mind or twitter has elon
musk after buying a seven percent stake
in twitter will not be joining the
twitter board and we will also talk
about a bill introduced by democrats
which would require employees be given
time off to vote um some folks thought
maybe you had that already but not in
this way so we're going to talk about
all of those stories on today's bonus
show i also want to remind you david
pakman show town hall one week from
today 6 p.m eastern on april 19th it'll
be streaming live on the pacman live
youtube channel that's not the main
youtube channel that's the other youtube
channel pacman live
everybody is welcome to participate and
lastly you can now gift memberships
at
joinpackman.com if you have a membership
already great
we have almost 700 people waiting for
free memberships you can sign up and
check that this is a gift box and we'll
give a membership to someone who's
waiting join pacman.com place to do it
we'll see you on the bonus show or
otherwise i'll see you back here
tomorrow